tu es connu
comme le michelangelo du métro de new york
mais tu ne veux pas être appelé la
gratitude pourquoi
[applaudissements]
je veux dire j'ai dessiné dans le métro de new
york pendant cinq ans
oui c'est comme ça que j'ai gagné le nom de graffiti
mais euh le problème est que les gens
ont tendance à ne penser
qu'à une seule chose quand ils pensent au
graffiti et en réalité j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses différentes
quelle était l'importance de felicinski
et
william burroughs dans votre décision de
peindre
eh bien c'était deux des  influences précoces,
je suppose que je veux dire burroughs à
cause de
l'idée conceptuelle de ce qu'il
faisait avec la littérature et
avec l'expérience psychédélique que vous connaissez
et avec euh
avec la façon dont il prenait les choses et les
découpait et les changeait
et
trouvait une sorte de  une signification spirituelle ou
psychédélique à l'intérieur des choses normales que
vous savez
et pour alexinsky était plus juste
formellement, ses choses étaient quelque peu similaires à
ce que je faisais à ce moment-là
et j'explorais aussi des choses  s en faisant
des choses abstraites qui évoqueraient des
images et d'autres sentiments et des choses
quand as-tu pour la première fois
peint dans un dans un métro dans un appartement ou dans une
boîte de nuit
quand était-ce dans le métro à new york en
1980 était le début
et qu'est-ce que  avez-vous bien peint dans le
métro j'ai commencé à
dessiner à la craie parce que dans le métro
je ne dessinais pas sur les murs je
dessinais sur
un panneau publicitaire vide et ils
n'ont pas assez de publicités ils avaient un truc vierge
alors j'ai commencé à  acheter de la craie et dessiner
dessus avez-vous commencé à peindre
dans le métro
parce que vous ne pouviez pas entrer dans un
vrai musée
à cette époque c'était une sorte de musée pour
vous c'était l'endroit idéal
pour que les gens voient le travail euh mais  aussi
à l'époque je ne vendais pas de
travail ou n'exposais pas dans des endroits
sauf dans des
boîtes de nuit et vous savez des petits
endroits comme ça
mais vraiment parce que le métro avait à new
york je veux dire qu'il y a des centaines de
milliers de personnes
chaque jour qui passent devant le dessin donc
tu ne peux pas  même
dans un musée, vous ne pouvez pas demander cela et
quand l'une de vos peintures est
-elle entrée dans le vrai musée pour la première fois euh
combien ici
plus tard en 19 1981 ou 82 a été ma première
grande exposition en galerie, puis en 83 ou 84
dans les musées
comment et quand vous êtes-vous rencontrés et le monde
euh bien la
première fois que je l'ai vraiment rencontré, c'était quand il
est venu à ma première grande exposition à new york
avant que je l'aie rencontré quelques fois
mais juste en tant que fan
vous savez demander  un autographe et
complètement nerveux et ne savait pas
quoi dire,
mais ensuite, par l'intermédiaire d'un ami commun, il est venu
à mon exposition
et après la première exposition, nous avons commencé
à échanger des travaux
et à devenir de meilleurs amis
, puis c'est venu à chaque exposition et
nous  est devenu
au cours des trois ou quatre dernières années est devenu
vous connaissez des amis pour bavarder au
téléphone et sortir pour manger et des choses
comme ça
et vous avez rencontré basquiat par warhol ou
par vous-même non non je connaissais
john michelle quand je suis arrivé à new
york parce que nous
il était il a grandi  à new york mais à
brooklyn mais il a
commencé à traîner sur la scène à
new york à peu près au même moment où je l'ai fait
alors je l'ai
rencontré en 1981.
peint avec la guerre mais tu ne l'as jamais fait pourquoi
euh en partie parce que jean michel voulais
-je dire
j'ai fait comme deux ou trois petites
peintures
avec andy que nous avons données à madonna pour
son cadeau de
mariage quand elle a épousé shawn est-ce que tu te
sens comme tes cheveux d'andy bien d'une
certaine manière
je veux dire que c'est presque trop
à prendre tu sais que c'est comme  Je veux dire
que c'est trop lourd à porter
ouais en quelque sorte sur vos épaules pour dire je
veux dire je comprends pourquoi certaines personnes établissent
des liens
et nous avions des choses en commun sur
la façon
dont nous euh vous savez traité l'art et la
vie
et fait  c'est plus courant et plus facile
pour les gens des choses comme ça mais
il y a beaucoup de différences à je
veux dire nous vraiment je veux dire je n'aurais pas pu
faire ce que j'ai fait
sans andy faisant ce qu'il a fait en premier
qu'est ce qu'ils vendent dans votre boutique à new
york  appelé pop-shop
euh surtout tous les imprimés vous savez des
choses imprimées comme des t-shirts et des affiches
et des jouets des choses comme ça surtout des
t-shirts donc
vous ne pensez pas que ce genre de
merchandising peut être
mauvais pour votre cœur vous savez qu'il
peut le minimiser non
je veux dire  vous savez, au début, il y
avait des critiques du monde de l'art et
cela a probablement eu un effet sur les
prix du marché de l'art et la même
chose pour andy quand andy a
fait des films et a interviewé des magazines
aussi ouais ouais c'était
je veux dire tu connais les prix  des choses d'andy
quand il était vivant étaient
comparées à jasper johns ou
liechtenstein était très très faible ouais
mais peu importe vraiment je veux dire je pense que
la valeur réelle d'andy
est beaucoup plus importante que lichtenstein
ou jasper john donc
je veux dire que je ne suis pas seulement  le faire pour de l'argent
donc je pense que
tu ne sais pas ouais et de toute façon pour moi la boutique
est euh correspond exactement à ce que j'ai fait
dans le métro
tu sais je veux dire si je n'aurais pas fait
la boutique et été
élitiste et  juste euh une douleur chère  ter
alors
je pense que cela aurait été plus mal
de rendre les choses disponibles
que pensez-vous de la
figuration française les gens de la balance comme les
combas de rosa ouais eh bien je suis ami
avec la plupart d'entre eux je veux dire que
je me suis rencontré pour la première fois je pense euh
derozan et kombus
et baron et et blanchard et louisa
dans euh très tôt comme 1982-1983
ouais tu aimes ce qu'ils peignent
ouais eh bien je pense que je pense qu'il y a maintenant
il y a une sorte de
culture internationale je veux dire je pense
qu'ils ont grandi
sur  beaucoup des mêmes choses sur lesquelles j'ai
grandi si c'était
vous n'avez jamais dessiné avant de peindre vous
ne portez jamais de blanc
ouais vous peignez directement oh ouais un
dessin avec de la peinture
ouais parce que c'est un direct et qui fait
partie de la raison je suppose pourquoi le
pourquoi  le nom des trucs de graffeur
parce que même
la façon dont je fais des peintures est
comme si quelqu'un faisait des graffitis parce
qu'il n'y a pas de croquis ou de planificateur,
c'est juste directement de votre tête sur
eux que vous aimez quand vous êtes
p  ainting les
gens qui te regardent c'est une sorte d'
événement tu aimes beaucoup
c'est comme quand tu peignais dans le
métro maintenant ouais on y était habitué tu sais
parce
qu'après être allé dans le métro aussi longtemps
je suis devenu beaucoup plus à l'aise avec ça
et maintenant  je fais souvent des peintures murales à l'
extérieur ou dans des écoles ou des hôpitaux des
choses comme ça
et euh et il y a généralement des gens qui
regardent mais
euh ce n'est pas un problème parce
que vous ne regardez pas les
gens que vous regardez la chose
tu fais ça
et j'ai toujours de la musique forte et donc je
sais juste où tu écoutes quand
tu travailles euh
surtout de la musique de danse comme de la musique sur laquelle
tu danserais et
j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui  sont des
djs à new york donc les gens font toujours des
cassettes pour moi combien coûte une
peinture de toi maintenant euh je ne sais pas maintenant
c'est ridicule en fait
ouais je veux dire je suis allé voir ce spectacle
il y a un spectacle à paris en ce moment
euh de dessins qui  je n'ai pas
mis la chemise c'est drawi  ngs que
ce revendeur a acheté à différents endroits
et
c'est incroyable pour moi le prix auquel
il vend et je ne peux même pas
croire à
quel point je veux dire beaucoup euh des centaines de
milliers de dollars je veux dire pour de
petits dessins qui étaient des autographes que j'ai
fait pour  des gens
comme vingt-cinq mille dollars, je veux dire que
c'est complètement net,
je pense que le marché est complètement fou en
ce moment, je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas d'
équilibre par rapport à la
valeur réelle de quelque chose, vous savez
et pour moi, c'est effrayant parce que j'ai toujours
utilisé  aller aux ouvertures et je ferais des
dessins pour des centaines de personnes
et maintenant ça me fait réfléchir à deux fois parce que les
gens prennent le dessin et ils les
vendent pour autant d'argent maintenant
c'est fou donc vous ne savez pas si quand vous
signez quelque chose
ils  le veulent parce qu'ils le veulent vraiment
ou s'ils pensent juste à l'argent
c'est parce que tout le monde pense juste à l'
argent maintenant c'est comme dessiner des billets de banque
tu veux dire ouais ouais
ouais et beaucoup de gens qui
collectionnent l'art non  w
ne se soucient même pas de ce que c'est ils ne
regardent même pas la chose qu'ils sont seulement
c'est comme un investissement c'est comme l'
immobilier ou
jouer à stockholm c'est tout où pouvons-nous
voir vos peintures à paris en ce moment euh
eh bien il y a un spectacle  de ces petits
dessins que j'ai faits en 1983. qui sont
dans
cette galerie appelée 1900 2000 sur du vrai
bonaparte dans une petite galerie
si vous n'étiez pas des enfants qui embauchaient quel peintre
seriez-
vous voudriez-vous être disons
euh je veux dire la réponse évidente  est
picasso ouais je veux dire que chaque peintre
veut être professionnel mais
si ce n'était pas ça alors euh et puis je
suppose qu'andy serait le prochain choix
et si vous deviez donner une définition de
vous-même,
que diriez-vous que vous connaissez des artistes dans
le vrai sens du monde,
ce qui signifie que vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
savez, je veux dire que je peux
construire des choses et faire dessiner
des livres pour enfants et
concevoir des meubles et construire des bâtiments ou
connaissez-
vous vraiment une vraie vie
vous